el fin de la era merkel tendrá que
esperar tras unas elecciones en que
ningún partido logró la mayoría absoluta
empieza una fase de negociaciones
complicadas que podrían durar meses
según los resultados preeliminares los
comicios se saldaron con el partido
socialdemócrata a la cabeza seguido muy
de cerca por la unión democratacristiana
que cosechó los peores resultados de su
historia la extrema derecha cayó al
quinto lugar y la extrema izquierda
entró por poco al parlamento tanto los
socialdemócratas como los
democratacristianos pretenden liderar la
cancillería pero necesitan tejer
alianzas
[Aplausos]
los votantes han hablado muy claro han
dicho quién debe formar el nuevo
gobierno han reforzado tres partidos
políticos los socialdemócratas los
verdes y los liberales antiético desde
2017 la cdu y el spd gobernaban en una
gran coalición federal un acuerdo con
pocas perspectivas de reeditarse ahora
los verdes y los liberales en tercer y
cuarto lugar tienen en sus manos la
llave para formar gobierno los posibles
pactos sobre la mesa son la llamada
coalición del semáforo compuesta por
social liberales y verdes y la llamada
coalición jamaica una alianza entre
conservadores liberales y verdes vive el
haber nivel de la gente que votó por cdu
csv quiere que asumamos la
responsabilidad y gobernamos caso
antiguo kgb animan y estamos convencidos
de que un gobierno bajo el liderazgo de
la unión es lo mejor para alemania y
tenemos una responsabilidad con estos
votantes las pestes
del anfield
flixster liderará el ejecutivo quien
consiga antes limar las diferencias
entre las distintas fuerzas en temas
como la lucha contra el cambio climático
o la política fiscal sea quien sea el
sucesor de merkel se espera que no sólo
gobierne alemania sino que determine el
futuro de la política comunitaria y el
rol de la unión europea en el mundo